when I left on Wednesday I told you not
to make everything more stupid or no one
would be going to Disneyland no
Disneyland for anyone no Disneyland you
understand me I've been turning this car
right around I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show damn it people every
time I sign off the internet every time
I finish the podcast I think to myself
the world can't get any dumber and then
the next time I come on I think things
were so much smarter the last time I was
doing a podcast and that's what happened
over the weekend we're gonna get into
all things and now file related and bend
the knee and kneel and Knights of knee
and all of it we'll get to all of those
things but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at ring comm so
rings mission is to make your
neighborhood safer okay that's what they
are there for burglars like to ring your
doorbell find out whether your home and
then break into your house this is how
they don't get shot well one of the ways
that you can prevent them from doing
this is when they bring the doorbell and
you have a ring video doorbell then you
can actually see their face you can talk
back to them if you are 3,000 miles away
they will think that you are still at
home plus you have the capacity to
actually call the police from your ring
video doorbell ring is amazing and they
have a new floodlight cam so when things
go bump in the night you'll immediately
know what it is whether you're home or
away the ring floodlight cam lets you
keep an eye on your home from anywhere
it's the ultimate in home security high
visibility floodlights a powerful HD
camera that puts security right in your
hands with ring you are always at home
right now go to go to ring.com slash
Bend that's ring comm slash Ben you get
a hundred and fifty bucks off the ring
of security kit the products are so good
that I've spent my own money on them
ring.com / Ben ring.com
/ band there's a reason they're so
popular and you're seeing the ring signs
pop out pop out pop up outside of other
people's properties you should join the
club
ring com / button for 150 bucks off the
ring of security kit again I use that /
pens that they know that we say you okay
so as I say everyone's that is the
quick summary of today's episode so we
can skip the rest of the show okay so
the stupidity begins with the NFL
everybody's trying to blame Trump for
the advent of the stupidity now Trump
has his own brand of silliness that he
has injected in here and I actually
don't think it's politically silly I
think is bad for the country
but I think it's politically smart but
we need to start off with a simple fact
the NFL politicized itself years ago
this idea that Trump politicized the NFL
is sheer nonsense it's just not true the
NFL made a conscious decision to allow
politics on the field okay they've done
this for years in 2014 you recall after
the Michael Brown shooting in Ferguson
Missouri the st. Louis Rams came out on
the field and did the infamous hands up
don't shoot pose as they were coming out
of the tunnel onto the field big deal at
the time did they get fined they did not
get fined it was nothing from the NFL
was fine with it no problem okay then in
Colin Kaepernick decided that he was
gonna kneel down from the national
anthem on this during a preseason games
at the NFL find him no they did nothing
but what did the NFL do they threatened
the Dallas Cowboys with fines if they
were police decals in the regular season
on their helmets after there was that
shooting of police officers by a black
lives matter associated radical in in
2016 so yeah so here's the headline if
you had the decal on your helmet they
would not allow you to wear the decal on
your helmet okay same here if you wanted
to wear cleats that paid homage to two
victims of 9/11 the NFL said you are not
allowed to do this some players did it
anyway and then the NFL ended up waiving
the fine but if you are even if you were
even special breast-cancer gear then the
NFL will threaten to find you if you did
it in endzone dance that was too
provocative the the NFL find you so the
NFL cracked down on everything except
for leftist political expression
everything except for leftist political
expression I assume that you know the
response would be well they didn't crack
down on Tim Tebow except the Tim Tebow
kneeling to do his own private prayer is
not really a political presentation
kneeling for the national anthem pretty
clearly is so the NFL had politicized
itself long ago and then president Trump
decided step in so let's be clear about
something there was a consensus until
the middle of last week until Wednesday
of last week when last we left our story
there was a consensus in the United
States kneeling for the national anthem
is a stupid thing to do it is an
unpatriotic thing to do this was the
general American consensus now there
were some people who said well it's
still patriotic to kneel for the anthem
because you're really trying to say that
the anthem isn't being fulfilled in the
way that it was meant to be fulfilled
okay you made the statement about the
anthem the anthem is one of the few
unifying features of American life they
did the American flag the national
anthem these are unifying features of
American life and to kneel for the
anthems
that you are anti-american okay does
there are plenty of ways to protest
against police brutality or systemic
racism these are things that you feel
the necessity to do listen I think that
you're wrong I think that you are you're
operating on faulty assumptions
according to the Washington Post there
been 761 police shootings this year nine
of them nine of them weren't of an
unarmed black person and of those nine
not on mine we're cases in which the
person was just sitting around doing
nothing in many cases there's
questionable whether there's serious
questions about confrontations with the
police so the idea of cops are going
around shooting people is in and of
itself ridiculous that they're going
around shooting people based on race not
a lot of evidence to support that that
said if you want to protest there are
plenty of ways to protest making a
specific statement that you're going to
bow down during the national anthem on
national TV it's a statement it's a
political statement and it says that
America is inherently steeped in racism
founded in racism and inescapably tied
to racism okay that's what that says so
Americans didn't like that if you look
at the polls Americans didn't like this
end it was actually hurting the NFL's
ratings the NFL had a a trio of serious
PR problems before the middle of last
week the NFL had the CTE scandal you
know the fact that if you get hit in the
head many times then you're likely to
end up or it's possible that you ends up
with brain damage they could end with
early death CTE is is a brain disease in
which you get plaque in your brain
essentially and that comes from too many
hits to the head so that was one thing
the NFL had to deal with the NFL also
had to deal with serious spate of
domestic violence incidents where a
bunch of their players were not going
around women and the NFL you recall this
with Ray Rice the NFL didn't know what
to do they sort of said that they were
gonna do something that it didn't do
anything and then they did something
again so that was the second thing and
then they had the Kaepernick thing all
of this was contributing to a drop in
ratings for the NFL and in fact
JD Power did a poll and it showed that
for whatever number of people were not
watching the NFL anymore who had watched
before 26% of those people said that
their number one reason for turning off
the NFL was the national anthem protests
they didn't like the politicization of
sport which makes sense we have to have
a water-cooler culture we have to have
something in common
we don't have politics in common we
don't have church in common we don't
even have entertainment in common but
sports seem like a pretty easy one right
bunch people run around after a ball how
do you screw that up well we found a way
to screw it up so the NFL was facing all
these
promise there is a consensus the
consensus was people like Colin
Kaepernick dholtze doing stupid things
not good for the country but should
Colin Kaepernick be fired because of
that probably not most people didn't
really feel like it was necessary to
call for a fireman didn't really feel
like it was important to to call for a
firing or if the owners wanted to fire
on their own recognizance that's their
that's their problem I mean right they
it's a private business if they want to
fire a Kaepernick that can fire
Kaepernick that's their call what it is
not is the government's job to get
involved the government should not be
involved in this now the reason those of
us on the right thought this is because
we don't like when the government or
government actors sound off on these
issues generally right how would we feel
if President Obama had said about
Brendan I SH the former CEO of Mozilla
that it's a good thing that Mozilla
fired him after all the guy was for
sitting it was for traditional marriage
I mean that's pretty discriminatory we
would evolve in fighting Matt would have
said what business is it of the
presidents of the United States to make
noises about that imagine for a second
to counterfactual let's say Tim Tebow
gets down on a knee but he doesn't just
get down on a knee to pray he gets down
on a knee because he's overtly
protesting the abortion culture in the
United States and let's say the Barack
Obama is the president he comes out and
he says that's inappropriate Sports is
sports cut that stuff out I hope Tim
Tebow gets fired somebody needs to fire
Tim Tebow let's boycott the NFL until
Tim Tebow is fired we already said wait
a second is that the job of the
president like - our job to decide
whether or not we want to watch a game
it's the owners job to decide whether or
not somebody gets fired so this was the
consensus stupid politics are stupid and
also it's the owners job and the patrons
job to decide whether they want to watch
something or fire somebody
this was the consensus it was pretty
well settled you weren't seeing a
significant increase in the number of
NFL players who were kneeling for the
anthem it was basically Colin Kaepernick
and now it's not even Kaepernick because
the guy doesn't have a job he's a crappy
quarterback so that is the lead up then
along comes president Trump now I'm not
sure that what President Trump did last
week was politically designed I'm not
sure that he meant to to start this fire
fight I think that Trump likes to say
things to audiences where the clap right
I think that's really as deep as it goes
for president Trump but the effect of
what President Trump does is that
President Trump whether he likes it or
not
basically no matter what he says it's
going to be taken the same way that
reverse I
ecology has taken with my three-year-old
so the way that I get my three-year-old
to eat her to eat her food as I say to
her sweetheart you're not betting no
you're not big enough to eat all that
food you can't eat all that food no way
and then she goes yes I can I'm a big
girl then she eats all her food
right well no matter what Trump says the
left responds like three-year-old so
whatever Trump says they immediately
respond with you say we shouldn't kneel
for the anthem not only will we kneel
for the anthem we'll stretch during the
anthem not only will we kneel for the
anthem will poop on the field that's
what we'll do just to show you cuz Trump
huh-huh
okay so Trump leads all this off with
statements that really are divisive and
not useful okay so here's the part of
what Trump says that's that's useful
what he says that's useful is kneeling
for the national anthem is stupid agree
everyone agrees but that's not enough
Trump goes further he gets back into his
full-on WWE TV persona and he decides
that he's going to call for people to be
fired right he's gonna go you're fired
he's even gonna bring out his old slogan
because he's not getting anything done
legislatively and everybody sort of
disappointed in him and people are sort
of frustrated so he's gonna bring back
an applause line in Alabama because
whenever he gets in front of a crowd
this is what he does Trump is a
consummate performer it's what he does
for a living he's not president for a
living he's a performer for a living who
happens to be president that's how he
got here he didn't get her through great
legislative leisure domain that's not
how he got here yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
play the tape of Trump and explain what
happens next in just a second but first
let me say if things feel chaotic if
things feel like we are on the brink of
a national disaster if it feels like the
the North Koreans could try to fire a
nuke at us at any moment because they're
making those kinds of noises if you feel
like natural disasters around the corner
you need to have enough food in your
house so you don't have to worry about
the the local grocery stores shelves
being non stocked you're not to worry
about the government being able to get
to you that's why you need to go to my
friends over at my Patriots supply and
get their new survival food supply for
just 99 bucks it includes one hundred
and two servings of breakfasts lunches
and dinners for less than a buck per
serving order now eight eight eight
eight oh three 14 13 eight eight
8:03 1413 or online and prepare with
been calm
it's just 99 bucks plus free shipping
which is a cheap price to ensure that
you and your family are taken care of in
case disaster strikes eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen prepare
with Ben's outcome go to prepare with
Ben come on pick that up again it's like
a one-time investment you never have to
worry about it again people the office
you've tried the food say it tastes like
home cooking so make sure that you're
taken care of and then you don't have to
worry about it
prepare with Ben dot-com 888 803 1413
okay so President Trump so president
Trump goes to Alabama and it's a rally
and he decides that it's time to drop
some red meat so here's President Trump
dropping the red meat wouldn't you love
to see one of these NFL owners when
somebody disrespects our flag to say get
that son of a chop that field right now
out he's fired
[Applause]
okay so the the the him condemning the
the players who kneel
I'm fine with that I've been doing it
for years now I think most people in the
United States have been doing it for
years he is the President of the United
States he is not a Breitbart commenter
he is not the local drunk at your pub
okay he's the presidents of the United
States and now it's time for the
president to be the president perfectly
fine for him to say people should not
kneel for the national anthem it
destroys a feeling of unity that America
is built upon we all strive to do better
not okay for the President of the United
States to say the owners should move to
fire people and that's not where Trump
stops so Trump goes to Twitter and he
unleashes a full-on hurricane five-level
tweet storm so here's what he tweets if
a player wants the privilege of making
millions of dollars in the NFL or other
leagues he or she should not be allowed
to disrespect our great American flag or
country and should stand for the
national anthem if not you fire find
something else to do okay so here is the
problem there are a couple of words here
to start that are a problem one aloud
right go back to that first tweet for a
second aloud okay so in that first tweet
should not be allowed by whom by whom
okay the NFL gets to make its own rules
if they decide they want to let these
dole to be dholtze that's their problem
but this allowed coming from the
President of the United States carries
the patina of government action Trump
probably doesn't mean that
okay Trump doesn't even have the power
to get a health care bill pass but this
is
the kind of stuff that the presidents of
the United States should be saying and
then when he says that they should be
fired again I ask you if the situation
reversed take off your take off your
partisan hat for a moment if he had said
no one should be allowed to kneel
against our great American law roe v
wade if not you're fired how would you
feel about that and if you say if you'll
find about that your line okay and here
is president Trump continuing along
these lines and then he tweets Roger
Goodell of NFL just put out a statement
trying to justify the total disrespect
certain players show to our country tell
them to stand ok like look this part I
don't have a problem with ok Roger
Goodell you know again private industry
I don't think the president the United
States should be saying this I agree
with the general sentiment again there's
a difference between when I say it or
you say it and the president says it
because he has a different role in the
American Republic this is not something
the president should be doing ok then he
then he continues again he just can't
let this thing go because he thinks he's
got a winner here and he does okay
here's the irony the irony is that Trump
does have a winner here so Trump says if
NFL fans refused to go to games until
players stop disrespecting our flag and
country you'll see change take place
fast fire or suspend so now he's openly
calling for people to boycott a
particular business until they suspend
to fire someone
imagine if Barack Obama said everyone
should stop patronizing chick-fil-a
until the owner of the business is moved
out of power would that be ok the answer
is no and then he says NFL attendance
and ratings are way down boring games
yes but many stay away because they love
our country League should back us again
it's just more and more of the same he
feels like he's a terrier with a bone
and now he's not gonna let it go and he
continues along these lines just never
ends great solidarity for our National
Anthem and for our country standing with
locked arms is good kneeling is not
acceptable bad ratings I don't know if
that was translated into North Korean
and then into Korean and then back into
English but in any case when he says
here you know I actually here's what I
suggested I said listen if you want to
show solidarity with the people who are
kneeling but you disagree with them then
put your hand on their shoulder or
something and then say after the game I
disagree with him but it's his right to
say what he wants to say and that's
America the Trump I think is sort of
trying to say the same thing there but
ok then if it says courageous Patriots
have fought and died for a great
American flag we must honor and respect
it make America great again and then the
choir starts singing ok so I agree I
agree with all of this
I agree with all of this but again he's
the president
I am a talk show host okay there's a
difference is that is that the the
finale of his great rant I think that's
a fan Alan Alan is great right then
that's not all he sends his Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin to go out and
comments on this to again why is the
president involved in telling private
businesses what to do okay as a
conservative I want the government less
involved in telling private businesses
what to do even if I disagree with what
a business is doing there are plenty of
businesses that I think are full of
Schmucks that doesn't mean that as the
president of the United States I get to
tell them what to do so again two things
can be true at once
you should not kneel for the anthem it
makes you an a-hole to as the president
of the United States
you should not going or you should not
go around telling other businesses to
fire people based on political
predilection okay this makes you
malfeasance in your duty okay so here's
Steve minuchin a guy most famous
recently for using taxpayers dollars so
he can take his wife on their honeymoon
or something here's Steve minuchin
explaining why why Trump is right - Jake
Tapper on CNN the NFL has all different
types of rules you can't have stickers
on your helmet you have to have your
uniforms tucked in what the president is
saying and I think the owner should meet
and they should vote on a rule this is
about respect for our military this is
about respect for our first responders
this is not about Republicans or
Democrats players have the right for
free speech off the field on the field
this is about respect for lots of people
and I don't understand why there's rules
that when the Dallas Cowboys wanted to
put stickers on their helmets out of
respect for people there they couldn't
do it okay right now why is the Treasury
Secretary of the United States
commenting on this why okay we complain
when Barack Obama and his and his
government got involved in trying to
regulate the name of the Washington
Redskins and we said why are you talking
about this go do your stupid job you
stupid okay and now everybody's time out
okay so why is this really happening
it's because Trump's actually doing
something quite clever okay whether he
means to or not what he's doing right
now is quite clever what he is doing is
he is saying I am on the side I right
here I'm on the side of the national
anthem of the flag I love it it's great
and then he knows the Democrats are
gonna respond like three-year-old
children and say yeah
would you like to flag you like the
anthem screw you I hate the anthem I
hate the flag food and that's exactly
what Democrats do ok naturally this is
exactly where Democrats go because they
just can't help themselves so here's a
former Maryland Democratic
Representative saying that all NFL
players should kneel in response to
Trump and she said Sunday I hope every
NFL player takes a knee in solidarity
with Colin Kaepernick against the white
supremacists who squats in our White
House so what happens a lot of the NFL
players do they decide that they hate
Trump so much they're gonna kneel for
the anthem so here's what the lefties
and here's what the right seats cuz we
now live in completely different bubbles
right we don't have conversations with
each other we don't talk with each other
we don't try to stand they understand
each other so here's what the Left sees
the left sees a bunch of people kneeling
to protest a President of the United
States making statements that are beyond
his Ken right the president should not
be commenting on the Siletz all kneel in
solidarity to show that we don't like
what the president said here's what the
rest of America sees they see a bunch of
people kneeling during the national
anthem that people have fought and died
to protect they see a bunch of people
disrespecting the flag that a bunch of
people have fought and died to respect
so what the Left did is they took an
unpopular protest movement but not a
protest movement that no one on the left
was seriously backing and then they made
it there they made it their rallying cry
this is what we're gonna rally around
now is this unpopular stupid thing and
Trump's standing over here going I love
the flag it's great look at all these
people kneeling it's not about me
they hate the flag hate the national
anthem mm-hmm right and it's it's so
everyone so the real debate here is not
even had the real debate is whether it's
appropriate to kneel for the flag half
the people kneeling about the flag and
national anthem are doing it
specifically to piss off Trump if you
think you're pissing off Trump you're
wrong okay
Trump is winning because of this even
here in one-back Ohio and Michigan and
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin by kneeling
during the national anthem are you out
of your mind
but the Democrats think they're gonna
win with the air base Trump thinks he's
gonna win with his base and they're both
sort of right they're both sort of right
so what breaks down the only thing that
breaks down is our capacity to speak
with one another Americans are the ones
who got hurt right we just want to be
watch our football and drink a beer and
be left alone that's all it's all we ask
is it so much I've been saying this
about sports for years I was saying this
when the NFL was trotting out beyond
say to do a blacklivesmatter routine
during halftime or ever Katy Perry who's
a very political person right I've been
saying this for a long time let me watch
my sports and leave me alone and they
won't do it and now Trump has just taken
it to the next level he's just taking it
to the logical next step and now
everybody's mad okay and now we have
nothing to talk about the ratings for
the NFL are going to tank because the
NFL is gonna defend its players people
are gonna get mad they don't want to
watch the players kneel for the anthem
they think it's unpatriotic because it
is now there are people who say it's not
unpatriotic for two reasons one is when
you kneel for the anthem then you're
really kneeling because you respect the
anthem right it's because you respect
the anthem so much and we're not living
up to it okay
this I seen I think is a poor argument
this runs in the same category as people
who say the burning the flag is showing
the highest form of respect to the flags
we're burning the flag to show the flag
doesn't live up to what we think it
should live up to okay that's not really
what kneeling for the anthem shows okay
the other thing is a little more
understandable that is it's not
unpatriotic to kneel because we're not
kneeling because we don't like the
anthem of the flag well not kneel we're
kneeling because we want to show Trump
that he can't tell people not to kneel
okay again stupid but not unpatriotic
but what a lot of people in the middle
of the country see is people kneeling
during the anthem here is what people
say and you're gonna see what you want
to see right here's what you're gonna
see LeSean McCoy right who is a running
back for the Buffalo Bills this is what
he was doing during the national anthem
not even kneeling stretching
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that's garbage thing to do
I don't care what reason you're doing
that for stretching during the national
anthems a garbage thing to do it's I've
been kneeling right kneeling is bad
enough but stretching is really just you
being a garbage person so President
Trump thanks LeSean McCoy for his
campaign donation 2020 because they
promise you this helps Trump this helps
Trump and then it becomes a big thing
right you've got national anthem singers
who are kneeling you had one do it at
the Seahawks Titans game right so you've
got the color guard out there and then
in the color guard is is out these are
men and women serving in our American
military standing there for the flag and
the national anthem singer is kneeling
in front of the people who are willing
to spend their lives in their lifeblood
protecting that flag in this national
anthem it's gross
[Music]
so after singing mania well because we
have to show that kneeling is important
kneeling is not important again you want
to show solidarity at the players don't
kneel just hold hands with them while
they kneel right here we're gonna lock
arms locking arms is Trump Trump himself
said I think he's right locking arms
fine right we're all part of the same
country as Lincoln said we must be
friends not enemies so we must be
brothers not enemies okay here's another
national anthem singer kneeling again
this is a Detroit in Atlanta
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so there are a lot of places where
people were booed right the Patriots for
example we're booed a bunch of them
kneeled and the and the crowd booed them
which i think is totally appropriate you
can hear them booing the players right
this is what Trump is done and this is
what the left fell right into Trump said
if you kneel you're unpatriotic and you
should be fired and a bunch of people
said I'm the left okay fine then we'll
all kneel so what are you doing you're
alienating your own audience here's a
montage with all the players around the
NFL kneeling into the Cleveland Browns
who kneeled the who knelt and then just
kept kneeling throughout the game cuz a
snake just let shot McCoy and here's the
Jaguars right there's the Atlanta
Falcons the Jets are the P some people
were locking arms okay so now I'm gonna
show you how this breaks down because of
what Trump did instead of this being a
debate about instead of this being a
debate about kneeling about police
brutality it's turned into a debate
about the national anthem itself and
about Trump Trump has taken what was a
tiny protest movement and turned it huge
and in the process polarized the country
in a politically intelligent way but in
a way that's not very good for the
country I'm gonna get to the hero of
last night and get a hero of yesterday
and then some of the villains okay so
we'll get to that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
friends over at blinka so you have a lot
to do today right I mean it's a Monday
you just came off a really stupid
weekend and so now you have a backup
email you got a lot of work to do you're
not gonna be able to spend a lot of time
reading are you just things that you
want to read well that's why we can get
in the car it's time for you to turn on
blankest
you need to download the blankest app
because it allows you to go through the
world's best books in 15 minutes or less
they boiled down the main points of
books into 15-minute power packets they
call blinks and then you can listen to
them it really is amazing I know a lot
of people listen the show people like
Dana Perino now use blankest and the
reason for that is because blink is is
just a tremendous way of gathering
information you can spend five hours
reading a book and come away with the
same amount of material that you would
in a 15 minute summary from blink --is
because how much of that book that you
read three months ago do you actually
remember and these are all the
non-fiction books that you'd want to
rate it's things like why nations fail
600 page book really good book do I
fifteen minutes worth of material in it
not really so if you listen to the blink
now you just saved yourself for you
saved yourself seven hours right the the
titles that they have that are just
derivative like two thousand titles it's
things like Thinking Fast and Slow
they're the famous Daniel Kahneman book
about how the brain works that's a
400-page book okay what are you remember
from it fifteen minutes worth of
material probably that's why blink cast
works blink us right now has a special
offer just for our audience go to blink
accom slash Ben right now and you get
your free trial or three months off your
yearly plan when you join today that's
blink as to be Li n K ist blink cast
comm slash men's to start your free
trial or you get three months off your
yearly plan blink is calm / ben if your
information junkie like I am blink astiz
indispensable go and check it out and
make sure that you use slash pens that
they know that we sent you okay so the
big hero of yesterday when all was said
and done was not any of the players who
were kneeling it was one player on the
pittsburgh steelers name is hala han
throw them in the way of a-- he is a
three he did three tours i believe in
iraq and afghanistan and he is a West
Point graduate he's an offensive tackle
for the presberg Steelers the entire
pittsburgh steelers team decided that it
was necessary not to come out for the
national anthem over all of this
stupidity and the entire pittsburgh
steelers team stayed in the locker room
except for Villanueva who served in the
line of duty in order to protect this
national anthem and protect this flag
and here is some video of Villanueva
standing for the anthem
[Music]
Chicago Bears they came out they all
linked arms didn't deal the only player
on the Steelers who came out was this
guy but he served in the military his
jersey his jersey sales no one's ever
heard of him his jersey sales
immediately skyrocketed to number six
that's good he is the hero of the day
and if you are an NFL fan I recommend
that you go online right now and buy a
villanueva Jersey let's send it all the
way to number one I'd like to see that
be the number one selling jersey not Tom
Brady not Aaron Rodgers this nearly
anonymous offensive tackle who served in
our military and stood up for the
national anthem in the flag let's do
that so go over to your your online
wherever you get your jerseys online and
go find Villanueva's jersey and buy one
because i think that the more americans
where the villanueva jersey the better
off we are the better off we are
obviously you know this guy is is the
hero of the day and this is the new
debate right Trump got what he wanted he
got what he wanted he wanted us to be
saying the heroes of the day are the
people who stood for the anthem and the
people who weren't kneel because that's
what we felt before but now a lot more
people are kneeling because they don't
like Trump and you can see the the
virtue signaling stupidity of the left
here I mean it really is astonishing
Alyssa Milano right the actress she took
a picture of her kid kneeling because
there's nothing better than politicizing
your own child I know it's just
wonderful I really object to this you
know as I say I have two kids under four
I keep them separate from politics
I don't even put pictures online of them
people who are willing to use their kids
for this kind of stuff I really don't
like it Alyssa Milano tweeted Thank You
Donald Trump for giving me opportunities
to teach my children the difference
between right and wrong hashtag take the
knee okay so what does a listen mallanna
object to does she object to President
Trump saying that people who kneel for
the anthem RSO B's is that what she
objects to or does she object to the
President of the United States saying
they should be fired
if the latter then what I would like to
know from Alyssa Milano is does she
stand up for the rights of people to
speak at Berkeley does she stand up for
the rights of people to work at Mozilla
Firefox does she stand up for the rights
of people to continue working at their
bakery if they don't wish to service a
same-sex wedding like how much freedom
in the workplace is Alyssa Milano for or
is this just you know virtue signaling I
think we all know the answer Stevie
Wonder did this
routine Stevie Wonder got down on one
knee as well so it's become a big
cultural thing now tonight I'm taking a
knee for America
that was a risky business there
Wow so Monica Lewinski joke here I won't
tell but in any case the the idea that
that you know this is somehow doing some
sort of great service to the United
States for the United States if you're
praying for America that's one thing
that's normally what we mean when we
kneel but this idea that we all have to
take a knee for America that this is our
solidarity is protesting the anthem so
American solidarity now is protesting
the things that we stand for that's
weird my favorite one of these by the
way was this surgeon who's the his name
is Eugene gue MD and he says I'm an
Asian American doctor and today I take
the knee to fight white supremacy this
currently has a 117 thousand likes on
Twitter
Eugene GU is a surgeon scientist hoping
to cure heart and kidney diseases and
babies he's blocked by President Trump
he's the presidents of gamma Chan Inc
and Stanford and Duke med school along
let me just say that if we're talking
about institutional racism I'm gonna go
with Eugene GU does not really get to
talk about that so much hey Jingu as i
say went to Stanford and Duke Medical
School and let's be clear about this 5%
of the American population is Asian 20%
of med school graduates are Asian last I
checked so if we're talking about
institutional racism I think they keep
picking for examples so all of this
resounds to Trump's benefit this is the
amazing thing right if you're a Trump
fan then you like all this if you're a
big Trump fan you like all this not
because you care about not because of
what it does to the country I think it's
terrible for the country but if you
think that Trump needs political support
the best way to earn political support
is to play this game that they like to
call a political sumo wrestling so sumo
wrestling is about you get the person in
the circle with you and then you throw
them out of the circle all right you get
your enemy in the circle with you and
then you throw them a circle so what
that means politically is you get
everybody to agree to a certain
proposition and then you take your enemy
and you throw them out of the circle
they don't believe in that proposition
most people in America like the anthem
most people in America like the flag if
you get your enemy somehow to make the
idiotic mistake
of somehow saying I hate the flag I hate
the anthem you have won and that's what
Trump inadvertently did because the left
is so damn stupid I mean so unbelievably
stupid like light years of stupid
basically the left does something dumb
with you
Trump does something dumber with regard
to the anthem and then the left of
something even dumber we are now in an
endless vortex of stupid and we have not
yeah it's a black hole stupid and
eventually we will emerge on the other
side MIT Romney will have been elected
in 2012 you want to emerge on the other
side of that wormhole that's how dumb
everything is it didn't end there by the
way Trump is now in a fight with members
of the NBA as well so Steph Curry said
that he wasn't gonna go to the White
House to meet Trump okay as I've said
before I think players have a right to
do this
I think Tim Thomas did that the the
goalie for the Boston Bruins he did that
with with Obama because he's a pro-life
guy and obama's pro-choice i think
that's perfectly acceptable Steph Curry
said he didn't want to meet Trump so
Trump instead of accepting that with
good grace or just moving on and saying
you know that's too bad I really would
have liked to meet him you know just
being gentlemanly instead Trump does
what he always does which is you can't
quit des fired right he tweets out going
to the White House is considered a great
honor for a championship team Steph
Curry is hesitating therefore invitation
is withdrawn
he wasn't hesitating he said he wasn't
gonna come so again that's the same
thing that Trump did with his economic
and jobs Advisory Council you remember
this after Charlottesville
all of them quit he said you can't quit
I just banded your council now so Korea
mmediately responded by taking the high
road he said this is beneath the
president
you know why he doesn't need to target
certain individuals either you know
rather than others I have an idea of why
but it's kind of it's just kind of
beneath oh I think of a leader of a
country too
to go that route it's not what leaders
do okay so he hits the left loves this
battle LeBron James also sounds it off
because we definitely needed the King to
sound off on all of this I mean our
lives who not be complete without LeBron
James political commentary here he is
just a little frustrated man just
because this guy that we've put in
charge has taught us tried to divide us
once again and obviously we all know
what happened with Charlottesville and
the divide that that caused then and now
it's even hitting more home for me now
even more because he's now using sports
as the platform to try to divide us
right okay so you know yeah I love again
that LeBron James had no problem with
Colin Kaepernick dividing us for
President Obama dividing us but Trump is
the one who's dividing us and this is
the point okay we are now living in
Dwight Eisenhower talked about the idea
of this military-industrial complex
we're gonna gut and get into wars that
were stupid because we have this
military-industrial complex that has an
interest in building up our armaments
and then using them so we'll get into
were that are done this is what
Eisenhower said in his farewell address
in 1961 okay well when it comes to
political cultural entertainment we have
a political entertainment wing a
political entertainment complex that has
an interest in culture wars stupid
culture wars culture wars that don't
benefit anyone except the politicians
and the cultural figures that's it they
don't find a fit Americans then help the
country they don't tie us closer
together they divide us right now we're
supposed to choose sports like if you
love America you're supposed to choose
NASCAR and if you hate Trump you're
supposed to choose the NFL in the NBA
this is the game that we're gonna play
now the only people who benefit from
this are cultural figures who get to
feel very special about themselves and
feel like they are culturally and
politically important and political
figures like President Trump will get to
make hay off of this now the left is
okay with this because the left
dominates the culture right this is a
point Ross dude hat is made over it over
at the New York Times he says the left
we've never
had a greater dichotomy between politics
and culture the right is dominating
politics and the left is dominating the
culture and that's because they act off
of each other
politics is people reacting to culture
and culture is people reacting to
politics but they also are clutched in
this love embrace right where Trump
loves this it's great for him
politically and the left loves this
culturally because great for them
culturally they get to complain about
America and talk about how terrible it
is and talk about Trump and win some
adherents and fans and double down with
their own base everyone wins with their
base the middle of the country everybody
who just wants a better country where we
can live together and respect each
other's opinions we all hate each other
and we think that were jerks now like
it's made everything significantly worse
this political entertainment complex is
I tweeted yesterday politics and
entertainment copulated and now they
both have syphilitic brain disease
politics has become infused with
entertainment oriented stupidity and
entertainment has become oriented with
politically oriented stupidity and that
means that both are worse off both or
what's off meanwhile we ignore the
actual policy problems so I'm going to
talk about the policy problems in just
one second but first you're gonna have
to go over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
become a subscriber to this the very
greatest in all podcasts you also become
a subscriber to the Michael Noel's show
which is happening at 12:30 today and
the Andrew Clavin show which is
happening at 10:30 today we do it live
four days out of the week for them five
days a week for me you got the show
perfectly live when we break on Facebook
and YouTube you still get to see the
rest of the show over at Daily wire and
then you also get to be part of the
mailbag which we do every Friday here
which will be a blast this week I'm sure
it is a blast every week plus you get
the website with banner ad free and you
can download the show later I ad free so
you got all of those things for $9.99 a
month subscription if you want the
annual subscription then all you have to
do is spend $99 a year so you get a big
discount from the monthly and you will
also receive as our gift to you this
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr okay
the greatest in all beverage vessels it
will make your life better in every
conceivable way it is made for capturing
the bodily fluids that come from the
eyes of leftist that's why it says upon
it leftist tears hot or cold so
ninety-nine dollars a year and you get
that so check that out as well if you
want to check us out later just listen
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud go over
to YouTube hit subscribe we always
appreciate your subscribership and your
reviews we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so well all of this is going
on and this just goes to show you that
Entertainment has overcome politics
entirely president Trump tweets this
okay so you had that giant tweet storm
at the NFL that's what everyone's paying
attention to you today because let's be
frank it's more fun and entertaining to
talk about that so here is President
Trump tweeting about North Korea
yesterday hey here is what he tweeted
last heard Ford just heard foreign
minister of North Korea speak at U n if
he echoes thoughts of little rocket man
they won't be around much longer
exclamation point so the President of
the United States is is threatening
nuclear war and calling the dictator of
North Korea little rocket man now so
he's adding and he's like it's like
little Marco and rocket man so that's
excited this happens and the blowback is
zero
why because we've been in your to this
but we've not been in your to the
cultural war so we pay more attention to
the culture wars then you know the
possibility of a nuclear conflagration
with another country so that's exciting
meanwhile on policy everything precedes
a pace right what's amazing about this
is you recall that when I last we left
our story I was talking about Jimmy
Kimmel in health care remember that like
a year ago like four days ago you
remember that well this was supposed to
be the healthcare push right Donald
Trump was going to ram through the
Cassidy Graham health care bill we were
finally gonna repeal these parts of
Obamacare we're gonna leave the the vast
majority of it in place but we're gonna
make some significant substance of
changes to it
Trump's closing pitch was the NFL is
stupid and full of sons of right
that was his closing pitch which is just
great you remember his closing pitch on
health care last time was my Attorney
General is terrible
so his closing pitch needs a little bit
of work and we're not paying any
attention into the health care stuff
meanwhile it's unclear whether the
health care bill is gonna pass so why it
doesn't the president focus on rounding
up the votes for that because he is
enjoying the limelight because again
he's a performer he's not a politician
so here's Rand Paul saying he's not
gonna vote for the Graham Cassidy bill I
think what it sets up is a perpetual
food fight over the formula what
apparatus and give it to Democrats say
this is a bad idea it's not repeal
however all that being said if they
narrow the focus to the things
we all agree on expanding health savings
accounts giving governor's more freedom
through waivers slowing down the rate of
growth of an outrageous or
out-of-control entitlement spending
sure I'd be for that but I'm just not
for this block granting concept because
to me that is an affirmative vote that
have agreed to keep Obamacare okay so
here he is this is Rand Paul's deck by
the way he's always too pure to vote for
things you know again I I like Rand Paul
a lot on a lot of things but in this
case if this is the best that we're
gonna do this is the best that we're
gonna do I mean Ted Cruz and Mike Lee
are saying they're gonna try and extract
concessions in order to in order to vote
on this thing which i think is the
proper stance that's what Rand Paul
should be saying if he wanted to make a
better piece of legislation but he's not
the only one so remember Republicans
only have 52 votes in the Senate they
lose three and the suckers done McCain
is already saying he probably won't vote
for it so that means they can only lose
two more Rand Paul's and other ones that
means any of vote lost anyone vote lost
in the Senate and this latest Graham
Cassidy you know Obamacare fix or
Obamacare change goes down in flames
Susan Collins is also saying that she
probably won't vote for it so this thing
is you know it's right on the brink this
is where the president's weight could be
useful Jake it's very difficult for me
to envision a scenario scenario where I
would end up voting for this bill
okay so again this is where Trump really
should be putting his efforts right now
that is not where he's putting his
efforts obviously okay time for some
quick things I like and then a thing I
hate and and then please when we break
don't ruin things more guys it's just
there's only so much more we can learn
okay time for some things I like so
Edward feasor I recommended one of his
books the other day that was the last
superstition here's a brand new book
that just came out called five proofs of
the existence of God
it's about Aristotle Platonists
Augustine Aquinas and Leibniz and it
talks about the the logical proofs for
God that that have been put forward over
history and that really have not been
well debunked by the secular theistic
movement and it is not the the usual
cosmological argument that you hear
usually what you hear when it comes to
the cosmological argument is everything
has a creator therefore God right if
everything has created therefore got and
then that usually leads people like Sam
Harris the the atheists I'ma be honest
podcast that should be fun it leads
people like Sam Harris to say well if
everything has a
who created God that's not what these
arguments actually say okay that's not
what the argument is and if you want the
fully fleshed out argument in readable
prose five proofs of the existence of
God by Edward feasor is a is quite a
good book I had an opportunity to speak
with Professor feasor a little bit
yesterday and clarify some of my own
questions about the arguments that he
was making in the book I think that it
is well worth while do I think that
these are dispositive do I think that
do I think that they absolutely prove
that God exists so I think it's possible
to argue I think it's possible to argue
with them but I think that they are a
good logical presentation of what an
argument in favor of God looks like that
isn't based simply on revelation so yeah
I think that that's that's a worthwhile
thing so again five proofs of the
existence of God from Edward feasor okay
other things that I like I love that
Nancy Pelosi who is the least hip person
in the world although she may have had a
hip replacement I don't know so maybe
she got more hip recently but in any
case Nancy Pelosi is very unhip and she
doesn't know who colin kaepernick is or
what football is or why she's here or
what's going on in the room around her
here she was yesterday trying to
pronounce Colin Kaepernick's name he
should see this as an opportunity
somebody a common current conference
company doing what he did says this flag
enables me to do this colin campaka do
good evening so well done Nancy Pelosi
demonstrating how cool you are okay
finally time for a thing I hate
the answer is everything okay but
besides everything here's a specific
thing that I hate so according to the
Washington free beacon late-night
comedian Jimmy Kimmel and Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer have
coordinated behind the scenes for months
to oppose Republican efforts to repeal
Obamacare Kimmel whose son was born with
a congenital heart disease has been an
outspoken critic of the Republican
efforts to repeal Obamacare because he
believes the most recent Republican
efforts to replace Obamacare don't
protect people with pre-existing
conditions like his son according to The
Daily Beast so he has done a bunch of
monologues this week he did something
after I left the air if you want to see
my monologue about Kimmel's monologue go
back to last Wednesday's episode I did a
very long explanation of what Kimmel was
saying and why he's wrong and why it's
not right to stand on your child's
health condition in order to promote
your views of health care in any case it
turns out that Schumer and Kimmel were
speaking Schumer encouraged camel to
speak out in opposition to Graham and
Cassidy's bill when it became apparent
Republicans would try to pass it so in
other words does Kimmel know anything
about the Bell did he make an
independent study
no he's Democrat so he talked to Chuck
Schumer he doesn't like anything that
touches Obama care there would be no
Republican program Jimmy Kimmel it back
end of story that's the whole thing so
long as that is the case that's all that
matters so long as that's the case that
is the only thing that matters right is
that he was never gonna back anything
Republicans had to propose so as a
political put up job and I think that
means something because we're gonna make
an emotional appeal then we should know
if you were planning to use the
emotional appeal in order to promulgate
your politics because you were talking
with partisans on one side you didn't
come to your own your own conclusions
you just talked to Chuck Schumer and
have it ahead and give you some talking
points all right so we will be back here
tomorrow in the meantime as I say
everything's getting ruined just stop it
take a break go out for ice cream enjoy
your family enjoy your kids enjoy your
neighbors we still live in the greatest
country on the face of the earth and if
we would look into each other's faces
once in a while instead of trying to see
into the blackness of each other souls
the darkness of each other Souls
then perhaps we'd all be a little bit
better off I'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]